als wir in den Süden der Ukraine reisen
sind die russischen Streitkräfte aus dem
großraumchasson abgezogen
täglich greift Russland mit Raketen die
ukrainische Infrastruktur an immer
wieder bricht die Energieversorgung
zusammen
[Applaus]
wir haben uns in einer Wohnung
einquartiert Grund unserer Reise sind
schwere Vorwürfe gegen die russischen
Besatzer massenhaft sollen sie
ukrainische Kinder verschleppt haben
stand September 2022 spricht die UNO von
1800 Kindern und Jugendlichen
die Ukraine selbst rechnet aktuell mit
mindestens 14.000 verschleppten
Minderjährigen
in einem bewaffneten Konflikt wie das
internationale Völkerrecht ist
bezeichnet und da ist ganz bewusst
die Verschleppung das Einsperren oder
auch verschleppen mit den Ziel von
Zwangsadoptionen als Kriegsverbrechen
normiert
wir fahren nach herson angeblich sollen
Kinder aus der vormals besetzten Stadt
auf der annektierten Krim und in
Russland festgehalten werden seit dem
Abzug der russischen Streitkräfte ist
Hassan zu Front statt geworden
mitten im artilleriegefecht treffe ich
Oleg
sie befinden sich dort entlang dort und
dort
mehrmals wöchentlich kommt er in diese
gefährliche Gegend und kümmert sich um
die Tiere seines verschwundenen Freundes
Beamer auch Oleg wohnte hier zeitweise
das Haus steht leer die Familie sitzt in
Russland fest alles hatte damit begonnen
dass die russischen Besatzer
ukrainischen Kindern eine Erholungsreise
auf die krim-angeboten hatten
jedesmal mein Freund Dima hat einen
jüngeren Bruder dieser wurde von seinen
Eltern als erstes in das Ferienlager
geschickt also fuhr er wird danach
folgte
als sich im Oktober 2022 die russische
Armee aus herson zurückzieht dürfen Dima
und sein Bruder nicht mehr in ihrer
Heimat zurück die Eltern reisen ihren
Söhnen hinterher seitdem sitzt die ganze
Familie in der russischen Hafenstadt
anapapa fest
nachdem Dima gegangen war fuhren seine
Eltern hinterher und überließen mir die
Schlüssel zum Haus
denn
jetzt
das artilleriegefecht wird heftiger
okay
wir bringen uns in Sicherheit
mitten im Interview ruft Alex Freund
Dima aus Russland an
[Musik]
zurückkommen
natürlich würde ich sie verstehen sich
ja selbst ich möchte wirklich unbedingt
nach Hause zurückkehren in meiner
Heimatstadt
warum kannst du nicht in die Ukraine
zurückkommen
das ist ein Armband so sind wir
gekennzeichnet wie Tiere
Diema muss abbrechen warum wissen wir
nicht es wird das letzte Mal gewesen
sein dass Oleg mit seinem Freund in
Russland sprechen konnte
[Musik]
Mascha hatte Glück auch sie ließ sich im
Sommer zu einer Erholungsreise auf die
russische Halbinsel Krim einladen Mascha
zeigt mir Bilder
am 22 September sind wir losgefahren und
am 1 Oktober waren wir wieder zurück
[Musik]
Politik habe damals keine Rolle gespielt
sie wären klettern gewesen hätten Tänzer
aufgeführt und ein Militärmuseum besucht
nach ihrem Aufenthalt kehrte Mascha in
das damals noch von den Russen besetzt
nach Hassan zurück
anschließend Reisen Maschas Geschwister
in das russische Sommercamp auf die von
Russland annektierte Krim noch ehe sie
heimkehren können zieht die russische
Armee aus Person ab seitdem werden die
Kinder in Russland festgehalten
vor mehr als einem Monat gingen sie
dorthin alles genaue Datum kann ich mich
leider nicht mehr erinnern
war das der einzige Kontakt da
ist sehr schwer zu Ihnen Kontakt
aufzunehmen
und jetzt komme ich einfach nicht mehr
durch ich komme nicht durch weil es
keine Verbindung gibt
[Musik]
ein paar Straßen weiter eine Mutter die
ihren Sohn vermisst
aber
dunkel das ist ein erholungskennzeichen
würde und dann als sie zurückkommen
sollten sagten sie plötzlich dass es für
die Kinder sicherer sei wenn sie dort
leben
sie will ihren Sohn zurück koste es was
es wolle
ich werde dich holen
bis heute sind viele ukrainische Kinder
nicht mehr zurückgekehrt von Anfang an
hatten es die russischen Besatzer vor
allem auf die ukrainischen
Kindereinrichtungen abgesehen
wie groß das Interesse der russischen
Besatzer an der ukrainischen Heimkindern
war
illustrieren Aufnahmen von
Überwachungskameras sie zeigen wie
russische Soldaten und Zivilbeamte in
einem Vorort von treson ein Kinderheim
durchforsten
Heimleiter wurde mir scagiac hier in
kurzer Hose führt an diesem Tag die
Russen durch das Haus
alle Russen die zu uns kamen waren alle
Mr x keine von ihnen gab seinen Namen an
kein einziger seine Position sein Name
und so weiter sie sind alle Mister X sie
waren alle namenlos es gab den FSB es
gab Soldaten niemanden nannte seinen
Namen
und seine Kollegen schaffen es ihre
Heimkinder in privaten Wohnungen zu
verstecken und so die Deportation nach
Russland zu verhindern
die Deportation ukrainische Heimkinder
wird in Moskau geplant
verantwortlich
Maria WoWa bellova Putins Ombudsfrau für
Kinderrechte bereits im März 2022
spricht sie von 1500 ukrainischen
Waisenkindern die nach Russland geholt
und über das ganze Land verteilt worden
sein sogar im hohen Norden jenseits des
Polarkreises in Russland sollen die
Kinder alles ukrainische vergessen viele
kommen in Pflegefamilien werden
zwangsadopiert russische Propaganda
Bilder die an einen pseudo religiöses
Rituale erinnern
und jetzt stehe ich hier und begreife
dass ich diese Kinder in zwei Monaten so
dramatisch verändert haben es ist
einfach fantastisch auf einem
Silbertablett werden
staatsbürgerurkunden überreicht
[Musik]
Konflikt oder auch einfach nach
Besetzung wenn nicht mehr gekämpft wird
möglichst viele Menschen zu Russen zu
machen und das natürlich bei Kindern
sowieso viel leichter dass sie dann
letztendlich am Ende sich auch als
Russen fühlen sollen
nach Russland verschleppt und zur
Adoption freigegeben Propaganda Bilder
doch sie verraten ganz nebenbei etwas
verstörendes
zunächst wie die russischen Pflegeeltern
mit ukrainischen Kindern zu einem roten
Ziegelhaus gefahren werden offenbar eine
Einfamilienhaussiedlung alles wirkt sehr
westeuropäisch
tatsächlich stehen die Häuser im
Moskauer Landkreis tomilino in der
Satellitenansicht erkennbar der gelbe
Bus mit denen die ukrainischen
Heimkinder gefahren werden dann die
Überraschung die Wohnsiedlung gehört der
internationalen Hilfsorganisation SOS
Kinderdorf
weitere Aufnahmen zeigen wie Putins
Partei Einiges Russland durch das
SOS-Kinderdorf marschiert
im dezember 2022 besucht Putins
Ombudsfrau für Kinderrechte das
SOS-Kinderdorf bei Moskau es entstehen
Propaganda Bilder mit verschleppten
ukrainischen Kindern
ist die renommierte
Kinderhilfsorganisation verstrickt in
das deportationsprogramm der Russen
die Hilfsorganisation räumt ein dass sie
von 13 ukrainischen Kindern in ihren
Kinderdörfern wisse und teilt mit
SOS-Kinderdorf Russland kann keine
Auskunft darüber geben wie die Kinder
nach Russland kamen und wie sie die
russische Staatsbürgerschaft erlangen
Russland und Putins Ombudsfrau entführen
ukrainische Kinder einige landen in
einem SOS-Kinderdorf die
Hilfsorganisation mit
Erklärungsversuchen SOS Kinderdorf ist
gegen den Einsatz von Kindern für
politische Zwecke wir unterstützen das
nicht und werden diesen Fall prüfen
die Verschleppung und Zwangsadoption von
ukrainischen Kindern ist ein
Kriegsverbrechen jede Beteiligung
Komplizenschaft